der präsident droht mit militäreinsatz
im eigenen land die friedlichen proteste
gegen rassismus in den usa gehen weiter
die ausschreitungen auch die koalition
ringt um ein konjunkturprogramm in der
diskussion eine kaufprämie für autos und
extra geld für familien und frankreich
tastet sich zurück ins normale leben
nach zweieinhalb monaten dürfen sich
alle wieder im ganzen land frei bewegen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers und abend hinein an
einem ereignisreichen nachrichten tag
danke dass sie dabei sind wir beginnen
in den usa die einen weiteren tag
erleben mit lautstarken protesten gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt und auch mit
den schwersten unruhen landesweit seit
den 60er jahren
und mittendrin ein präsident der nicht
zu mäßigen versucht sondern noch anheizt
donald trump droht damit das militär
einzusetzen gegen die eigenen bürger
das hier ist die szene vor dem weissen
haus gestern abend das ist ein
durchgehend friedlicher protest dann
plötzlich eine halbe stunde vor beginn
der ausgangssperre beginnen
sicherheitskräfte des bundes die
menschen zu vertreiben mit tränengas und
blendgranaten wie sich herausstellt um
den weg freizumachen für donald trump
der einen speziellen fototermin geplant
hat vor einer kirche heute ein weiterer
solcher termin aus washington in das
trans am morgen noch einen termin mit
religiösen bezug präsident fand besuch
den schrein für papst johannes paul den
zweiten
er will das bild des gläubigen
präsidenten geben der die lage unter
kontrolle hat gestern hatte schon mit
nationalgarde und polizei eine
friedliche demonstration am weißen haus
auflösen lassen gummigeschosse und
tränengas
zeitgleich wandte er sich an die nation
nicht mit einer botschaft der empathie
aber der härte die proteste setzte er
gleich mit terror eine rede für seine
wähler
ich werde euch beschützen ich bin euer
präsident von recht und gesetz seinem
eigenen volk droht er mit dem militär
wenn sich eine stadt oder ein staat
weigern die notwendigen maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um das leben und eigentum
seiner einwohner zu verteidigen werde
ich das us militär einsetzen und das
problem schnell für sie lösen
nach meinem verständnis reagiert eine
gouverneurin ist die zustimmung der
bundesstaaten dafür notwendig die wird
es von vielen staaten nicht geben nach
seinem statement wird klar warum trump
die demonstration hat auflösen lassen
für einen bizarren fototermin vor der
kirche am weißen
house ungelenk hält er eine bibel hoch
auch dass eine botschaft für seine
anhänger die zuständige bischöfin
entsetzt
dies war eine farce es sollte seine
botschaft unterstützen die beruhigt aber
nicht die seele des landes oder zeigt
uns einen weg aus der krise
das aber brauchen wir von einem
präsidenten in der nacht kreisen
militärhubschrauber tief über washington
um die demonstranten einzuschüchtern
kommt weiß dass er mit seinen taten und
worten die lage nicht beruhigen wird er
setzt auf konfrontation
da bringen wir unseren amerika
komponenten mit dazu el mati wissen
immer guten abend eine harte haltung des
präsidenten drohungen mit dem militär
gegen die eigenen bürger zunächst mal
darf trump so etwas also der präsident
beruft sich auf ein gesetz aus dem jahr
1807 und dass sie tatsächlich vor dass
wenn es zweifel daran gibt dass in
irgendeinem bundesstaat das recht
tatsächlich durchgesetzt werden kann
dann kann der bundestreffen entsenden
aber und das ist die meinung
überwältigende meinung der
rechtsexperten hier in den usa
er kann das in diesem fall nur dann tun
wenn er tatsächlich von den gouverneuren
der einzelnen bundesstaaten darum
gebeten wird da gibt es natürlich auch
abweichende meinungen und es kommt dann
am ende auf den präsidenten an ob er es
vielleicht doch einfach macht auch wenn
die rechtslage rechtslage unklar ist so
wie wir es vergangene nacht hier am
weißen haus erlebt haben dass der
friedliche demonstranten hat vertreiben
lassen für einen fototermin
es kommt auch auf die bilder der
nächsten tage an gibt es viele
plünderungen und ausschreitungen gibt es
in der überzahl friedliche
demonstrationen sowie da ist auch in den
vergangenen 24 stunden der fall war wie
mein kollege johannes hano aus new york
berichtet
das ist unsere heimat ruft der
polizeichef von new york und dann kniet
er sich zusammen mit den demonstranten
hin
jeden tag im ganzen land hunderttausende
auf den straßen friedlich demonstrieren
die allermeisten gegen polizeigewalt und
gegen rassismus und immer mehr
polizisten solidarisieren sich mit ihnen
im ganzen land wie auch hier in
kalifornien versuchen polizisten mit
solchen gesten die situation zu
entspannen
ich denke polizei ist hier um euch zu
schaden
ich sage euch ich bin seit 34 jahren
polizist ich habe vielen geholfen und
niemanden verletzt ich bitte euch uns
nicht diese schublade zu stecken
mein polizei die partner liebt euch aber
immer wieder bricht sich die gewalt bahn
es sind szenen wie in einem bürgerkrieg
und immer mehr verwischt sich wer
eigentlich dafür verantwortlich ist
in seattle kämpft ein demonstrant
wahrscheinlich mit einem zivilpolizisten
schnellfeuergewehre genau lässt sich das
aber nicht feststeht in philadelphia
schießen polizisten tränengas und
gummigeschossen eine gruppe die kein
fluchtweg mehr hat in atlanta film und
zwei studenten dem übergriff und
sicherheitskräften und werden daraufhin
mit einem elektroschocker geäußert auch
journalisten wie dieses australische
fernsehteam werden immer mehr zum ziel
von polizeigewalt mehr als 100 polizei
attacken auf journalisten sind bislang
dokumentiert aus dem friedlichen protest
zügen aber lösen sich auch wie in der
nacht in new york gruppen die geschäfte
plündern und zerstören die lage auf den
straßen eskaliert und es wird immer
schwerer zu sagen wer dafür
verantwortlich ist
unter die friedlichen demonstranten
mischen sich gangster aber auch rechts
und linksradikale die den staat
zerstören wollen
und auch viele sicherheitskräfte heizen
die stimmung immer wieder auf amerika so
sieht es aus wandelt am abgrund immer
noch mal zurück nach washington
vielleicht das ganz große bild elma an
dieser stelle
es gibt ja noch diverse andere probleme
im moment 100.000 über 100.000 corona
tote in den usa 40 millionen arbeitslose
und jetzt das da kommt enorm viel
zusammen zur gleichen zeit wie sehr wird
all das die usa verändern
ich glaube das wird spuren hinterlassen
auf der seele der menschen hier in den
usa auf das ganze land wir haben in der
tat die ihm einerseits eine
gesundheitskrise die möglicherweise
durch große menschenansammlungen ja noch
verschärft werden könnte wir haben die
wirtschaftskrise und jetzt droht
gewissermaßen eine regelrechte
staatskrise der präsidentschaftskandidat
der demokraten hat gesagt den
präsidenten ginge es ja nur um macht und
nicht um die prinzipien der
amerikanischen demokratie
darüber wird man sicherlich im wahlkampf
in den nächsten monaten streiten aber
die entscheidende frage ist wer von den
kandidaten hat tatsächlich konzepte um
die wirtschaftskrise um die sozialen und
auch die ethnischen ungerechtigkeiten in
diesem land anzugehen und zu bekämpfen
und darüber werden die wähler dann am
zweiten november hier in den usa
abstimmen
live vorm weißen haus el mati wissens
hervor schenkten herzlichen dank die
europäische union unterstützt das recht
auf friedlichen protest ihr chefdiplomat
verurteilt heute gewalt und rassismus
jeder art giuseppe sagt alle leben
zählen auch schwarze leben zählen mehr
gleich in einem zdf spezial unruhen in
den usa militär gegen demonstranten
gleich nach uns und ich empfehle ihnen
die zdf- heute- app natürlich dort gibt
es einen schwerpunkt zu diesem thema und
jetzt in der sendung nach deutschland in
die berlin in der berliner politik da
geht es heute um viel viel hilfe und
viel geld die koalition sitzt an einem
konjunkturpaket und da liegen dutzende
themen und vorschläge auf dem
verhandlungstisch im kanzleramt
der gesprächsbedarf bzw der
diskussionsbedarf ist so groß dass der
tag heute dafür nicht ausreichen wird
dazu gleich mehr live aus berlin
erst zeigen mathis feldhoff 100 um was
es alles gibt
wie vor dem kanzleramt wussten zumindest
was sie nicht wollten einen kauf bonus
für die autoindustrie die drinnen waren
sich bei dem thema noch nicht einig wie
auch bei etlichen anderen entscheidungen
die in ein weiteres konjunkturprogramm
münden sollen so wurde kurz und knapp
beschlossen finale ergebnisse gibt es
das morgen jetzt kommt es wirklich auf
jeden schritt an es geht darum
unternehmen zu sichern arbeitsplätze zu
sichern was für die kommunen und die
kinder auf den weg zu bringen
wir wissen dass wir zeit brauchen es
gibt ein paar punkte die noch geklärt
werden müssen und jetzt nehmen wir uns
zwei tage zeit
doch maßnahmen wie die kaufprämie für
autos direkte finanzhilfen für die
kommunen oder ein kinderbonus für
familien sind heftig umstritten
der wirtschaftsflügel der union fordert
eine breitflächige hilfe es gibt
branchen in deutschland die machen kaum
bis gar keinen umsatz die messebauer
alles was mit veranstaltung zu tun hat
tourismus auch bereich gastronomie
hotels stationäre handel
denen müssen wir jetzt helfen während
die koalition noch ringt mahnt die
opposition die richtigen akzente zu
setzen es geht darum öffentliches geld
auch gezielt einzusetzen
dort wo jeder euro am meisten bringt und
nicht einfach mit der gießkanne geld zu
verteilen und schulden zu machen als
gäbe es kein morgen meine befürchtung
ist allerdings nach den letzten tagen
und dem hickhack in der groko dass es
wieder viel zu viel geld gibt für
techniken der vergangenheit das geld
gesteckt wird im verbrenner prämien das
geld gesteckt in große konzerne morgen
mittag geht es in die zweite runde
schon jetzt ist klar dass erneut
milliarden von euro fließen werden zwei
runden eine sehr lange sitzung das heißt
viel zu besprechen das geht ja auch um
viel geld statt controller banerjee
beobachtet dass wir uns in berlin
charter ist ein absehbar wer profitieren
wird und wer nicht das wenn man jetzt
mal alle ideen zusammen nimmt die cdu
csu und spd damit in die
verhandlungsrunde gebracht haben dann
muss man sagen alle die besonders
betroffen sind von der krise da geht es
um förderungen und um entlastungen für
unternehmen für arbeitnehmer für
familien für kommunen um nur mal die
größten punkte zu nennen insgesamt rund
60 vorschläge liegen auf dem tisch die
werden sicherlich nicht alle umzusetzen
sein auch weil einige davon schwer
umstritten sind bei der koalition
wir hören aus der runde dass es ernste
beratungen sind in konzentrierter
stimmung aber dass es eine sachliche
debatte gibt denn immerhin muss man
sehen alle sind daran interessiert
ergebnisse zu bringen alle möchten auch
dass ihre partei die eigene handschrift
mit einbringt denn es geht um vorschläge
und um ein konjunkturpaket das in den
nächsten anderthalb jahren wirken soll
und dazu gehört dann eben auch das
nächste jahr das ein wahrer ist da
wollen alle greifbare ergebnisse haben
und was ist mit der ja nicht ganz
unwichtigen frage ist das alles zu
bezahlen
ja das ist natürlich eine große frage
alles wird man nicht haben können wenn
man in dem rahmen bleiben möchte den man
sich gesetzt hat
wir hören dass es um ein paket von
maximal 80 milliarden euro gehen soll
das wäre dann nicht das grösste
konjunkturpaket wenn man es einzeln
betrachtet für sich genommen
es gab 2008 2009 nach der finanzkrise
schon ein größeres aber man muss ja
sehen dass das ganze paket jetzt drauf
kommt auf die summe die schon eingeplant
ist mit den hilfsmaßnahmen die schon
beschlossen wurden das sind über 150
milliarden euro also da kommt eine menge
geld zusammen hilfsmaßnahmen in
unbekannter höhe
da müssen die maßnahmen auch wirklich
wirken damit deutschland das geld am
ende auch wieder erwirtschaften kann
ich sage aber vielen dank und dann
gucken wir jetzt auf die entwicklung der
pandemie in deutschland die aktuellen
corona zahlen zeigen die neuinfektionen
gehen weiter zurück
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage steckten sich täglich 430 menschen
an
insgesamt registrierte die johns hopkins
universität seit beginn der pandemie
fast 184 1000 infizierte davon gelten
mehr als 166.000 500 als genesen 8500 63
menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
unsere nachbarn in frankreich hat die
korona pandemie deutlich schwerer
getroffen als uns und die
einschränkungen waren sehr viel massiver
als in deutschland
der tag heute ist für die franzosen ein
ganz besonderer nach zweieinhalb monaten
dürfen sie sich jetzt erstmals wieder
frei im ganzen land bewegen
cafés bars sind wieder offen aus paris
berichtet thomas walter morgens um
sieben ist die welt fast wieder in
ordnung dass karriere kaffee darf
draußen öffnen mit auflagen
zwischen den tischen muss mindestens ein
meter abstand sein das möchte ich jetzt
mal nach da haben wir ein lied einst
passt also wegen der auflagen erlaubt
die stadtcafés teile der straße zu
nutzen nach zwei monaten zwangspause
geht es um mehr als nur croissants und
kaffee
das ist herrlich findet ihr auch oder
das ist wunderbar eine echte freude
die sonne scheint das ist perfekt und
das ist die freiheit die freiheit kommt
langsam zurück wie die kunst auch
anstehen am museum marmottan monet
das hat mir gefehlt den direkten kontakt
mit einem kunstwerk kann man nicht
ersetzen
doch auch hier kommt die freiheit nicht
bedingungslos wir müssen den abstand
zwischen besuchern erhöhen im inneren
des museums wir empfangen darum nur ein
achtel der üblichen besucher in unseren
ausstellungsräumen die auflagen machen
vieles unrentabel nicht alle geschäfte
und restaurants überleben die krise die
parks öffnen wieder hier und da fällt es
schwer die alte form zu erreichen
aber langsam ganz langsam findet paris
sein gleichgewicht wieder zurück nach
deutschland in hamburg haben spd und
grüne ihren koalitionsvertrag für die
nächsten fünf jahre vorgestellt
als schwerpunkt der gemeinsamen arbeit
nannte hamburgs erster bürgermeister
peter tschentscher den wohnungsbau die
bildungs- und verkehrspolitik ein
zusätzlicher senator von den grünen soll
sich ausschließlich um die verkehrswende
kümmern
auch maßnahmen zur bewältigung der
korona krise spielen eine zentrale rolle
spd und grüne regieren die hansestadt
seit 2015 ein schock ein einschnitt war
das vor genau einem jahr der mord an
kasseler regierungspräsidenten walter
lübke und auch wenn es heute angesichts
der korona beschränkungen keine große
gedenkveranstaltung geben konnte die tat
wird nach auf der terrasse vor seinem
wohnhaus wurde walter lübke in der nacht
zum 2 juni erschossen
das motiv sieht die bundesanwaltschaft
in der rechtsextremistischen gesinnung
des mutmaßlichen täters stephani in zwei
wochen soll der prozess beginnen gegen
ihn und seinen mutmaßlichen komplizen
mehr dazu jetzt von susanne santina
walter lübke war beliebt gilt als
bodenständig und menschen er wurde
ermordet wohl weil er sich für
flüchtlinge stark gemacht hatte am
regierungspräsidium kassel wurde ein 20
meter großes banner gespannt in
erinnerung an walter lübke demokratische
werte sind unsterblich dafür stand er
der hessische ministerpräsident bouffier
beim gedenken am grab seines
parteifreundes
das war eine vorbildliche haltung hat
haltung gezeigt und er hat es mit seinem
leben bezahlt und das macht es so
tragisch und auch so ganz
außergewöhnlich es war in der nacht zum
2 juni 2009 10 als walter lück auf
seiner terrasse mit einem kopfschuss
getötet wurde
auf seiner kleidung fanden sich
dna-spuren die schnell zu stephanie
führten einem vorbestraften neonazi mit
verbindungen zu rechtsradikalen
organisationen stephanie hatte zunächst
gestanden dann aber markus h beschuldigt
die bundesanwaltschaft wirft diesem
beihilfe zum mord vor
er habe stefanie in seinem vorhaben
bestärkt und ihm den waffenhändler
vermittelt die linke in hessen
kritisiert dass stephanie vor zehn
jahren vom radar des verfassungsschutzes
verschwand es gibt fotos und belege aus
dem jahre 2011 begehen davon aus es gibt
fotos aus dem jahr 2014 wo er an
veranstaltungen von neonazis
teilgenommen hat und 2016 wird er jetzt
auch angeklagt im januar 2016 soll
stefan er nämlich in lohfelden einen
irakischen flüchtlingen niedergestochen
haben
außerdem so die anklage soll er den mord
an walter lübke lange geplant haben er
soll sein haus mit wärmebildkameras
ausgespäht und schießen trainiert haben
der prozess gegen den mutmaßlichen
mörder von walter lübke beginnt am 16
juni in frankfurt beim sport jetzt noch
mal zurück zu dem thema mit dem wir auch
begonnen haben die proteste gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt in den usa
gibt es weltweit diese proteste und auch
in der fußball bundesliga mit einem
schriftzug am trikot oder kniend auf dem
spielfeld dabei sind politische
statements während des spiels eigentlich
verboten hermann fall größer berichtet
ihre gesten sorgen für aufsehen der
schalker mit kenny mit justice for
george oder seine dortmunder kollegen
hakimi und sancho statements gegen
rassismus nach dem gewaltsamen tod des
afro amerikaners floyd der gladbacher
tür am knie tauss empörung und die
vereine finden die ausrufezeichen
mündiger sportler gut wenn sich jemand
gegen rassismus stellt dann hatte glaube
ich von vielen menschen von den meisten
auf diesem planeten volle volle
unterstützung und deswegen gute aktion
ein dilemma für den deutschen
fußball-bund politische botschaften im
wettkampf laut reglement verboten der
kontrollausschuss ermittelt noch während
dfb präsident fritz keller lebt ich habe
großen respekt vor spielerinnen und
spielern die haltung haben und ihre
solidarität zeigen solche mündigen
spielerinnen und spieler wünschte ich
mir auf sie bin ich stolz top liverpool
mit trainer klopp oder chelsea mit
nationalspieler rüdiger viele machen
mobil
aber auch im wettkampf wollen viele
profis nicht länger schweigen die
aktionen werden voraussichtlich
straffrei bleiben erfuhr das zdf aus
kreisen des dfb
obwohl der verband solche proteste auch
in zukunft lieber abseits des rasens
dann finden wir eine politische
botschaft gut und richtig war falsch
darüber kann und muss man mitunter
diskutieren nur im spiel geht das nicht
und da die motivation die aussagen der
spieler vom wochenende aber ohne zweifel
zu begrüßen sind werden die sportrichter
im aktuellen fall sicher zu einer
salomonischen bewertung gelangen
offen bleibt ob ein kniefall zum
präzedenzfall wird er ist auf jeden fall
ein starkes zeichen gegen rassismus in
der formel 1 soll es wieder losgehen
nach vier monaten corona pause heute gab
es den notfahrplan
zunächst sind acht rennen in europa
angesetzt
los geht es in spielberg in österreich
mit gleich zwei rennen
am fünfter und zwölfter juli ohne fans
an der strecke zuschauer sind nicht
erlaubt
und deutschland ist leer ausgegangen der
hockenheimring steht nicht im neuen
kalender der formel 1 vom wetter hat
noch diese nachrichten morgen gibt es
die ersten schauer und gewitter mehr
gleich von gunther tiersch jetzt gleich
das zdf spezial um 21.45 das
heute-journal und morgen sind wir wieder
für sie da und zwar sehr gerne machen
sie sich alle einen angenehmen
dienstagabend
[Musik]
liebe zuschauer jetzt wird es wieder
regnen und diesen regen können wir
wirklich gut gebrauchen die luft wird
feuchter und deshalb entstehen morgen
schon schauer und gewitter über
mitteleuropa und diese kühle luft hier
über großbritannien die erwarten wir am
donnerstag dann mit kräftigen gewittern
dazu ja auch heute nacht gibt es im
westen immer wieder regenschauer im
osten lassen die jetzt nach es wird dort
auch kühler sechs bis acht grad morgen
früh werden es hier im westen 15 grad
mild bleibt tagsüber am vormittag
wechseln sonne und wolken erste
regenschauer gibt es dann von der
nordsee bis zum 1
und nachmittags breiten sich schauer und
vor allen dingen gewitter aus bis zur
elbe etwa da ist es noch östlich davon
sonnig und wir haben nur an der ostsee
in kräftigem ostwind auch im süden
scheint die sonne aber zum abend hin
wird es dann die ersten schauer und
gewitter im schwarzwald geben die
temperaturen unverändert war aber es ist
eben auch noch feucht und schwüle 23 bis
28 grad an der ostsee mit dem ostwind
ein bisschen frischer 17 grad etwa und
der donnerstag wird dann wechselhaft bei
uns von westen schon wieder kühler und
am wochenende zeitweise regnet es ist
kühler und dazu auch noch windig ich
wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend und
machen sie es gut